warning the following video contains
spoilers for rogue one a Star Wars story
guys you've seriously got to learn how
to spell rogue
[Music]
you remember a new hope you member Darth
Vader now prepare to member the handful
of years between the rise of Darth Vader
and the start of a new hope we call it a
Death Star
oh they're gonna just rehash everything
from the Star Wars aren't they I've got
a bad feeling about a Rouge one a Star
Wars story get ready for Disney's first
Star Wars anthology movie because
there's no way in hell they'd call it
Star Wars prequel number four and what
has to be the most money anyone's ever
spent to fill in a plot hole that's the
place on Lake my trap that answers your
most pressing questions how exactly did
the rebels get the plans to the Death
Star did they grab a data tape with a
giant claw machine then use a big
antenna to beam the data tape to a ship
and then did that ship transfer the data
to another smaller tape and then to
Princess Leia cubby that's Margie under
a tiny droids hard drive you know
whoever said this one is as good as
empire must be really into file formats
meet an all-new gang of rebels you how
do I put this shouldn't get too attached
to like jyn erso the rebellious rebel
who rebels so hard she does whatever her
dad tells her we will whatever her
surrogate dad tells her go with him too
you must go and whatever her new
co-worker tells her but sometimes she's
pretty grumpy about it hmm
rebelling alongside Jin is k2s Oh at raw
with more personality than any of the
human characters I'll be there for you
kassian said I had to Cassie in a rebel
whose most heroic moment comes when he
doesn't murder someone for once I had
every chance to pull the trigger date I
saw Guerrera an extremist cast out of
the Alliance by extensive reshoots to
rid the blind guy who's technically not
a Jedi but I mean come on look at this
guy and his friend ghanima cute face
I'll add more but that's pretty much all
there is to this guy cower before the
might of the Empire as various old dudes
squabble over who gets credit for the
death star we stand while down on the
battlefield stormtroopers are rolling
out in two brand-new flavors but with
the same old incompetence we're used to
whether they're missing easy shots
casually getting taken out or setting up
their weakness to sticks that the Ewoks
would take advantage of
[Music]
why do they even bother with the armor
at all enjoy one of the most beautiful
Star Wars films to date that feels like
the world's biggest budget fan film full
of Easter eggs that will have diehard
fans saying call Brent later
plus up the guardians of the Wills I get
that reverence
hey it's prequel guy blue milk cool ok I
like him so that's where those Cantina
guys were they were walking around t 15s
yeah I'm going to look that one up later
whoa what an awesome way to put talking
in the movie
never mind and this feels wrong somehow
but nothing will service fans harder and
faster than Darth frickin Vader has a
much older sounding James Earl Jones
tries to give us a new iconic see who
let George Lucas write a line but just
when you think he's been wasted extend
your lightsabers for the most badass
Star Wars moment put to film the hallway
see
which makes Bader's next fight in the
timeline even sillier than it already
was more tricks not storing the
following shots you saw in the trailers
that weren't in the movie gin versus a
TIE fighter the crew working together
actual heist eight war-torn scaris this
iconic shot of gin undercover unused
fader
soccer errors other haircut the shot
they based the whole marketing campaign
on all these other cool shots and this
line this is a rebellion isn't it
IRA bail okay cutting that would make
sense
suicide squad and unnecessary star war
story hundred foster forces with me I
won with the force enforcement with me
that's not how the force works think the
Internet has enough star war shows think
again we've launched an all-new show
with professional youngling Jenny
Nicholson to explore the outer rim of
the Star Wars universe watched this week
as she tackles what Star Wars creatures
would you eat then puts her credits
where her mouth is in the ultimate
galactic taste test
what is this meat Oh gross its screen
junkies Millennium Falcon weekly and
it's free every Saturday on screen
junkies news I know him he's a friend
from work I want that Mulan McNugget
sauce more tea I popped my pads
I can't wait for Disney to announce the
Michael Bay slash M night Shyamalan
co-directed Jar Jar a Star Wars story we
all float down here this is how we do it
it's Friday night